gabriel how are you
good
always a pleasure to be here steve
okay today i have the honor the pleasure
of talking to my friend gabriel silva a
fellow vancouverite a fellow polyglot
originally from brazil
and uh we're gonna talk about two
subjects uh one
why he's a polyglot what he gets out of
being a polyglot and two to touch again
on the subject that i covered briefly
with uh leonardo portugal differences
between brazilian portuguese and
european portuguese remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you follow me on podcast service
please leave a review
gabriel uh nice to see you i'm in palm
springs uh with my fake bookshelf uh
you're i think in vancouver i am you are
a very accomplished uh polyglot uh i
have heard you in a number of languages
unrelated languages russian turkish you
name it
what motivates you i know what motivates
me but i want to hear from you and i
think it would be
it would be interesting for my my
viewers
what do you get out of being a polyglot
why do you do it
well i i lo i absolutely love this
question and uh
right now i think that you know the my
motivation goes through phases uh
initially when i started really learning
and getting into languages uh it was
because i was just individually
attracted to to different cultures so
you know it was i learned english and it
took me forever to learn english and
really
get to a
very fluent level
and then i was just like well like it
seemed to really suck at learning
languages so i just want to actually try
to learn french and german
then i started learning them at the same
time and i uh i had a personal challenge
that i
wanted to be
because i love paris so i just actually
i lived there for uh for a year i may go
back i don't know when and
i
had this personal challenge that i
wanted to communicate with parisians in
french
and it also took me forever to
accomplish that and to to get to the
point that my french was decent enough
for parisians not to switch to english
immediately
and um and then it was also really into
i actually dated a german girl
and i fell in love with the with germany
so i just i would go there and i wanted
to
um to learn german as well especially
because it seemed like such a difficult
language so it was also a bit of a
challenge so then when i when i managed
to learn those languages and reach
fluency i was just like well you know
like i
now i know how to learn a language so i
just started
go you know getting into different ones
and uh
because i i was attracted to russian
literature i thought like why not
someday learn russian so that i can
actually understand tolstoy and i
thought it was going to take me 20 years
to learn russian but it was quicker than
i expected
and then i started getting into chinese
and i started dabbling into a ton of
languages and then i found my
uh an even greater motivation which is
actually something that i
i didn't uh
originally suspect it would would really
happen but
it's just how languages connect people
and that's something that i that
fascinates me so much because
you know one thing that i absolutely
love to do um
and this may seem random but i just i
always like to you know strike up
conversations on the streets uh i talked
to random people like i was uh i was in
london for a little while um after i
went i lived in paris and uh
uh it was just so much fun to just you
know start start up talking to people
and when you're a polyglot
and you speak these like these different
languages and you you know you hear like
whatever i would hear some chinese start
speaking chinese
i i would hear some uh turkish of you
just like oh
is that turkish oh you're from turkey
and
the barriers just disappear
it's just absolutely insane how quick
they disappear
i want to pick up on some of the things
some of the themes that you mentioned
that i think are very important first of
all we become a polyglot one language at
a time now we may study two languages at
the same time but we begin by learning
one other language and then another
language so at the beginning on the sort
of journey towards becoming a polyglot
it starts one language at a time for
whatever reason we're motivated to learn
one language we're motivated to learn
another language we realize we know how
to do it we can do it and then it kind
of snowballs that's very much been my
experience the second thing you're
saying is that languages connect us and
and i think if we look at like what's
the purpose of life i think we are never
happier than when we are connecting with
other people
and we can connect with other people
like in the here and now
or through books and movies and we can
connect with people in far away
countries or far away centuries and so
the opportunities to discover
human
human beings human activity is is so
much enhanced by learning different
languages so
the things that you mentioned are
absolutely i totally agree with what you
have to say there yeah absolutely and
like that i uh one person that comes to
mind
is uh
ahri uh selma new york city oh yeah
right and he because he uh and basically
like i do do something like similar
videos like in a different kind of
context really because i
um
and he connects he goes and he gets an
amazing reaction from people because his
mandarin is so good
and um and it's just amazing to see
how like uh barriers just like
absolutely dissolve between people
so it's important in doing that to make
it about genuine communication and not
simply about performing
uh yeah no absolutely yeah we have to
make sure that we genuinely want to
connect with those people we don't want
to just use them as a prop
i'm not saying that harry does that but
i think it's very important to do to do
this whole thing with respect
one thing i should say uh you are a
genuine polyglot genuinely interested in
people in literature and so many
different things but i should point out
that one of your major activities is at
your youtube channel
you help brazilians with their english
or other languages i'm not entirely sure
and um you know brazil people maybe
don't fully realize like it's like the
united states like it's 200 million
people it's a huge country so a lot of
people a country with again a
mixture of peoples from you know
different parts of the world including
the indigenous people it's a fascinating
country with tremendous potential and
your
sort of single-handedly helping them
overcome the obstacles that language
schools put in front of them in terms of
learning languages what are some of your
messages to your followers in in brazil
i would say you know um first one of my
messages will for sure like
listen to steve like check out his
channel he's got so much incredible
advice
and second really is what you know like
what i always say just like really
um
take language learning into your own
hands and don't really just depend on
the little course that you bought and
that you're that you're doing
because
the language learning process is fun you
should be engaged in it you should
um get exposure to the language as much
as you can to to things that you like to
things that you enjoy
and um because
a lot of students really have this
passive attitude towards learning a
language especially in brazil it's
changing now you know but that's
especially brazil everywhere like it's
everywhere everywhere unless you live in
europe where the neighboring countries
speak so many different languages yeah
in brazil it's
less motivation to learn i guess
no of course but the thing is just like
i think that um it's just because
the a lot of brazilians are very they
have they have like a traditional
mindset a more orthodox uh way of
thinking and you know there's nothing
wrong with that but just like the the
mentality is normally yeah like i'm just
gonna go take a course to learn the
language right and
rely on that rely on and not go that
much further but it is changing and like
you said yeah it's
it is a universal problem uh to many
especially for example like in north
america first thing that pops up when
you say oh i
i'll pick up duolingo or rosetta stone
to to learn a language and that's just
the the way that people
think about it normally like the average
person right if they when it comes to
learning a language if they go that far
if they go that far exactly
listen one last thing uh we can talk
forever we always do of course um so
brazil is this fascinating country 200
million people i'm not sure i have the
stats right but it's around 200 million
people mm-hmm uh and yet it's 210 maybe
it's very big 210
and portugal in europe is a much smaller
country 10 million people but of course
for europeans it's a much more likely
tourist destination than brazil because
brazil is not much further away
north americans may be more likely to go
to brazil i don't know but for people
who want to learn the portuguese
language how important are the
differences between
portuguese and europe in in
portugal or for that matter mozambique
or wherever else portuguese is spoken
versus the form of the language or the
different regional forms of the language
in brazil how important are all these
regional
varieties of the language for our
learning uh i think that a lot of
portuguese people may disagree with me
but i would say that they're not that
relevant really in the sense that
especially for instance the that is a
question that i get for english all the
time too like oh should i learn british
english or should i learn uh
american english or australian english
if i'm going to australia i would say
learn english learn the language um and
then really worry about your your
specific uh local accent or dialect
later but of course that you know like
you may encounter some minor issues if
uh let's say you you learn american
english and then you move to scotland um
you know they have a theory yeah
yeah
that's an extreme example you're in
glasgow and then like you're gonna be
struggling to understand then of course
you can get a lot of exposure to content
from that area to just
get acquainted with the the accent and
the funny thing too is just like for
instance
just even in the uk alone there's so
many regional accents scouse is so
different from
any accent from the the south or even
the geordie accent in newcastle but
anyway so the portuguese basically there
is just so much uh
content in brazilian portuguese really
and in brazil we have so many also like
different accents
uh genius so like basically um slang and
all sorts of different things but i
would say learn the language and of
course
portuguese and portugal is very
beautifully spoken it tends to be more
formal
of course they have their slang as well
but uh often if you get exposure to a
lot of content from brazil you may come
across a lot of uh local slangs and and
things that are going to be used in
brazil that are not going to be used in
portugal and there will be were you know
vocab that's going to be different as
well i love portugal i've been there
twice and uh it was just very
very like i'm fascinated
about like the different little
differences you know like sometimes it'd
be just like a word that's just like oh
you guys
say that you know like
yeah but but you're
at a very high level obviously in all
languages but in particular in your
native language
i think the average beginner
would have trouble telling whether this
is brazilian or portuguese wouldn't even
know
um
as is true with spanish as is true with
all these other languages that have
different regional variations
so you can't even hear the difference so
beginners shouldn't worry about these
differences they should just learn words
and certainly when i was learning
portuguese i listen to both portuguese
and brazilian i want to be able to
understand people
uh wherever they may come from and so i
tend to feel that people make too much
of an issue out of this you know which
variety are you going to learn is this
portuguese from portugal or is it from
brazil
you have to get pretty good you have to
be well into intermediate before you can
even hear the difference yeah
absolutely i think that like
i've heard uh some people say like oh
you know portuguese from portugal sounds
more like russian to a foreign person
versus brazilian portuguese may sound
more like
i don't know like
some broken form of spanish or whatever
like whoever doesn't speak the language
or whatever but um yeah i think that you
know steve you're absolutely right
because you need to learn
the language then if you just really
want to focus on a specific area let's
say that you're learning portuguese and
then you want to move to to lisbon or
you want to move to
porto or
versus sao paulo or bahia
you know you're gonna you can then later
worry about it
um the regional accents the regional
like slang way later in the game if you
really don't know the language at all
you may think portuguese sounds like
russian
once you know words you're more focused
on the words and at that point the
differences become less important if you
don't know the language at all you would
think that greek and caste like iberian
spanish are the same language because
they have the same science that's nasa
but they don't have the same words at
all and but once you know the words it's
hard to tell if the person is mexican or
spanish because you're now focused on
the words and overwhelmingly in
portuguese like from you from europe or
from brazil it's the same words and it's
the same grammar
period
more or less
yeah well i say like obviously you know
the the portuguese and that's something
that i've noticed in portugal for
instance they speak very they speak very
elegantly you know the the portuguese
they're very proud of portuguese
language right and even for example like
sometimes on my channel every now and
then a portuguese person says like oh
hey you know like listen this is
brazilian that's not portuguese you know
that's a different language but it's it
is the portuguese language of course
that you know there there are many
um
you know
differences uh in terms of especially
vocab in the in the long run but when it
comes to
when it comes down to it it is
the same language essentially and it's
the same for example like let's say
let's take spanish for instance
someone from colombia normally
the colombian accent is regarded as a
very clean and
pure
um they speak very clearly and so on so
and then if you take someone from chile
chile has a lot of
yeah they have like a lot of regional um
slang they they they cut the words and
especially because they they're more uh
geographically isolated right by the
and andy's and stuff uh andy's
i don't know yeah um
so then if you
but you know if you if you're going to
move to chile
you're going to learn spanish anyway
then later you like when you're like you
said when you're at an intermediate
level
right then you're going to be really
you know wanting to focus on the
regional accent and so on right but it
is the spanish language it doesn't
really you know with gabriel is that we
always agree on everything
so uh that point of agreement
learn portuguese it's a wonderful
language there's i don't know 250
million speakers around the world just
learn the language don't worry about
which version and that applies to
whether you're learning portuguese or
spanish or french or english or chinese
or any other language
gabriel as usual
i we could speak for hours but maybe
we'll just stop it there and thank you
very much for coming on my channel
sounds good always a great pleasure
steve